vous ne faites pas preuve d'instruction...
Un langage approprié requiert : « Ça roule ? »
Vous pensez peut-être que cela fait trop banlieue, que ce n'est pas cool.
Je vous annonce donc que même notre langue a ses règles.
Et quand Maman se moque de moi et dit :
« Tu vas kiffer raide faire les boutiques et j'en prends pour mon rhume... »
Je réponds : « Maman, non, il y a une faute de grammaire.
Prendre pour son rhume ne peut jamais être un verbe pronominal réfléchi.
C'est la grammaire de cet 'anglais' là. »
Si j'avais un talent de chanteuse,
je chanterais ceci du haut des montagnes,
dans chaque banlieue, dans chaque quartier :
« La seule langue divine est celle de la Genèse de ce monde
qui dit : 'Ceci est bon' ».
Et donc, lorsque je vous parle, mon langage n'est pas toujours châtié.
Mais cela ne vous autorise pas à me juger et d'assumer que je suis
trop peu cultivée pour enseigner, car je parle 3 langues :
Une langue pour la maison, une pour l'école et une pour les amis.
Je suis trilingue. Il m'arrive de rester consistante avec mon choix de langue,
ou de changer en cours de route par facilité.
Il m'arrive de réprimer deux langues
quand j'utilise la troisième en classe.
Et quand je me mélange les pinceaux,
cela me met mal à l'aise, comme si je cuisinais dans la salle de bain.
Je sais...
mais j'ai dû emprunter votre langue
parce que la mienne, on l'a volée !
Mais n'espérez pas que j'épouse pleinement votre histoire
alors que la mienne est brisée.
Ce sont les paroles d'une personne qui est simplement exaspérée,
des idéaux eurocentriques qui ont cours.
Et la raison pour laquelle je parle une version composite de votre langue,
c'est parce que la mienne, on l'a violée, avec mon histoire.
Je parle un anglais argotique pour que ses nombreuses entailles nous rappellent
que notre situation actuelle n'est pas le fruit d'un mystère.
J'en ai marre des images négatives, sources de colère pour mon peuple.
À moins que vous n'ayez vu mes cheveux faire un hold-up,
ne les appelez plus « mauvais ».
Cela me rend malade de voir ces différentes connotations raciales.
N'appelez plus vos cheveux « bons », sauf s'ils font des dons.
On a dérobé tant de choses à mon peuple.
Comment pouvez-vous croire que je puisse considérer sa trace sur votre anglais
autrement que son égale ?
Soyons clair !
Il n'y a pas matière à confusion : ceci n'est pas l'apologie de l'ignorance !
C'est une célébration linguistique.
C'est pour cela que j'ai mentionné « trilingue » sur mon CV récemment.
Mon message aux recruteurs est que je peux les aider à diversifier
leur marché de consommateurs.
Et quand ils me contacteront pour un entretien,
je serai ravie de pouvoir leur montrer que je sais dire : « Ça va ? »,
« Ça roule ? » et naturellement : « Bonjour ».
Parce que... je suis bien « instruite ».
Merci.
(Applaudissements)